good the weirdest [__] I ever ate Was a
Teddy Graham with maggots on it
but you see the weirdest thing
I have a mom she doesn't like it when I
have snacks she would only make her
whack-ass food raw card rice stained
glass window bread but all her shit's
whack it's always just digging through
the cabinets I found some Teddy Grahams
in the back oh what's this and I opened
it but it was old and there's a little
bit of maggots and I was like but I'm so
hungry and I ate it so you dusted the
maggots off I clicked one of them off
the texture was so weird that's not how
Teddy grams taste like let's not do dumb
like childish stuff let's do like actual
cultural food Delicacies you just said
you didn't say you added duck as well I
don't know right now I didn't think we
were gonna get the Teddy Graham maggots
we ate live octopus they tastes like an
earthy clam you know huh they deep fry
it Nick he wants to cut that [__] it
yeah uh actually it seemed like a real
freak though